(relaxing music)
Well, we're gonna start
with peripheral vascular disease,
a very important topic, not only for the board exam,
but definitely for your patients.
And to do that, we're joined by Dr. Robert Dachs.
Bob is the Director of Graduate Medical Education
and part of the Department of Emergency Medicine
at Ellis Hospital in Schenectady, New York.
He is also a clinical associate professor
in the Department of Family Medicine
and works with the family medicine residents.
He is a board certified family physician himself,
part of Albany Medical College in Albany, New York.
It's great to be here and to do the course once again.
So peripheral vascular disease, yes,
there's usually two or three questions
you'll have on the boards of peripheral vascular disease.
I hope to cover what might show up for you.
Got nothing to disclose.
Here's my learning objectives
and when I do peripheralvascular disease lecture,
I like to begin at the beginning.
Let's start with the aorta and work our way down.
So we talk about two aortic diseases,
aortic dissection and abdominal aortic aneurysm.
Let's do the one you're gonna possibly see more of,
which is the bottom one, AAA, abdominal aortic aneurysm.
But even before we get there
and we start talking about aneurysms,
it's always good to know,
what's the definition of an aneurysm?
So the aneurysm is when the vessel diameter is greater
than 50%, it's normal size.
So a typical abdominal aorta
is approximately two centimeters in diameter.
So when it gets to three centimeters, you have an aneurysm.
How common is it?
It's very common.
2% to 5% of the elderly population
harbor a abdominal aortic aneurysm.
Completely asymptomatic, it's just there,
doesn't bother them.
But it won't bother them until it typically ruptures.
And it's the 14th most common cause of death
in the United States.
What causes AAAs?
Atherosclerosis, too many Big Mac attacks.
And in particular smoking,
smoking is really associated with developing a AAA.
Where are they located?
95% of them are below the takeoff
of the renal arteries or infrarenal
and there's, more men than women have it.
As I mentioned, they're asymptomatic
until they go,
(Dr. Dachs vocalizing)
until they rupture.
And once they rupture or leak,
60% to 80% of those people die
before they make it into my ER doors.
Of those who make it into the ER doors,
50% of them don't leave the hospital alive.
So incredibly high mortality associated with a ruptured AAA.
Therefore you want to prevent that, that's what we do.
Alright, so "Because of the prevalence and it's lethality,
the USPSTF recommends ultrasound screening
be performed on which patients?"
Okay, because of its prevalence and lethality,
the rupture of AAA.
Does USPTF say, "A, we recommend a one-time screening
for men ages 65 to 75 who have ever smoked.
Onetime screening for men 65 to 75,
regardless of their smoking history.
C, onetime screening for both men and women,
ages 65 to 75 who have ever smoked
and D, onetime screening for both men and women,
ages 65 to 75, regardless of their smoking history."
Because you know this, it's one time screening
for men who have ever smoked.
Definition of ever smoked
is 100 cigarettes in your lifetime.
Now here is your take home slide,
David likes to say take these slides home,
this is one of them, it just says what I just said,
there's a B recommendation for the men.
As for the men who have never smoked,
don't know, it's a C, you can consider it.
There's too little evidence in women who have ever smoked
and a D for women who have never smoked, don't go there!
Just don't go there.
Now, not being a sexist on this.
I always put these sort of slides in, not for you to study,
but just to back up what I say.
So when you see some of my slides
that may mention this trial, that trial, this trial,
don't memorize the trials.
They're not gonna ask you the name of the trial,
just the take home message
and the take home message on this Chichester Trial
that was done in England
took all these women over 65,
randomly assigned them the screening versus nothing
and it made no difference, it made no difference.
So don't go screening women,
particularly ones who have never smoked for a AAA screen.
Now there is one caveat, this is not what the USPSTF says,
but what our government allows.
So Medicare part B does allow for men
who have ever smoked, aged 65 to 75
or men or women regardless of their smoking history
if they have a first degree relative who's had a AAA,
they will pay for a AAA screen.
So that's what Medicare says,
which is different than what USPTSF tests says.
So just understand the difference,
'cause in practice you may be doing what Medicare tells you,
understand what the academics are from USPSTF.
Next question, you happen to have found AAA on that screen,
'cause you had a male who smoked.
At what size should you refer them
for surgical intervention?
When should you send them out to the vascular surgeons
or your interventional radiologist?
Is it when it's three to three and a half centimeters,
four to four and a half centimeters,
five, five and a half centimeters,
Six or six and a half centimeters?
Good, most of you know this one,
it's five to five and a half.
They've asked this question in the past, so just be aware.
Will it come up again?
I don't know, but it is five to five and a half centimeters.
And here's why.
Up to five, five and a half centimeters, there's no issue,
it doesn't rupture,
for the most part, there's not a problem.
Once it hits five, five centimeters,
then that aneurysm starts to grow
bigger, faster, quicker, and
(Dr. Dachs vocalizing)
then may go.
So the rate of increase is exponential.
The larger the diameter, the aneurysm,
the faster it's gonna get bigger and bigger.
So the question is, you've got an ultrasound report
that says X amount of centimeters in diameter.
How frequently should you be repeating that ultrasound
to follow it?
This is one of the recommendations
from the vascular surgeons who say, listen,
those small ones,
you get a report three and a half centimeters.
When's the next time
you should actually look at that again?
In like three years,
'cause the small ones grow very, very, very slowly.
If they're bigger and bigger and bigger,
you go more frequently.
Let's move upstream back to dissection,
up here in the chest.
So dissections, who gets them?
Men more than women.
Hypertension is the leading cause of a dissection.
There are other causes, cardiac surgery, Marfans
or other connective tissue diseases,
cocaine use in the peripartum region.
Now I'm gonna make one mention about Marfans.
There was one question once on inservice,
so I threw in one slide on Marfans.
Everybody thinks Marfans, everybody thinks Abraham Lincoln,
but there's other signs and symptoms of Marfans
or I should say signs,
not say symptoms, sternal abnormalities,
such as those things, abnormal joint flexibility.
One of these I like to point out is the Steinberg Sign,
that's where you take your thumb,
put it in the palm of your hand
and you wrap your fingers around it
and if you have abnormal flexibility,
you'll see your thumb come out past the hypothenar eminence.
So you go like that.
Yeah, I see a couple of you people doing this.
Yeah, you doing this?
(audience laughing)
I see a couple people just said holy crap, I can do that!
(all laughing)
Don't freak, it's only one sign.
And actually if you go to the Marfan Syndrome website,
there's actually a scoring system
that if you get more than seven points,
that's who you should refer for genetic testing.
I'd like to go back
and just mention one thing about dissection and AAA,
they're not the same thing.
The pathophysiology is different.
This is my artist's rendition of a AAA.
You see a true aneurysm,
all three layers of the vessel wall will dilate out,
intima, media and adventitia, the whole thing goes out.
What happens in a dissection, up here in your chest,
is after that hypertension, longstanding hypertension,
you'll get an intimal tear.
And with that intimal tear,
you'll now create a second lumen inside the media.
It becomes a two lumen problem is what a dissection is.
And there's two types of dissections,
there's the ascending, type A, descending, type B.
That's easy, make it easy on yourself, A is ascending.
How do these people present?
How do patients present?
I think everybody learned
like in the first week of med school, dissection,
oh, that's a tearing ripping interscapular pain,
everybody learned that?
Well, actually it's interesting,
more commonly it's anterior chest pain.
Anterior chest pain, well think about it.
Two thirds of dissections are type A
from the ascending aorta.
Where is your ascending aorta?
It's an anterior structure,
so they have anterior chest pain.
As the dissection moves along,
it may then involve your descending thoracic aorta.
But it starts more commonly, the type As,
with anterior chest pain.
How do you make the diagnosis of a dissection?
Any way you can.
(Dr. Dachs laughing)
Most commonly, well, in the ER now,
the quickest, easiest to do is a CTA a CT angiography,
that's what I show you here
and I don't know if you can see it,
but I put the arrows there, you can see two lumens.
You see two lumens, there's two lumens here
and that's how you make the diagnosis.
If you make the diagnosis, what do you wanna do?
You actually wanna lower the blood pressure,
you wanna stop this thing from progressing on further.
Now we are gonna work our way downstream
and talk about the more common things
you'll see potentially in your office practice.
That's peripheral vascular disease
that presents with claudication,
classically in the lower extremities
or an acute thromboembolic problem
that will present with The 5 "P's."
Let's do the thing that shows up in your office,
which is a claudication.
This is really, I like to put this definition,
because it just explains everything.
Claudication is right there,
"Reproducible ischemic muscle pain
that occurs with exercise, relieved with rest."
In other words, it's stable angina of the legs.
So when you have angina, coronary angina,
because you've got a fixed lesion, you exert yourself,
there's not enough supply and demand
and so you get chest pain, you stop,
the pain goes away, that's angina.
Well what happens with claudication?
It's angina of, typically the legs.
You can have the upper extremities,
but you have this fixed lesion
somewhere in your lower extremity, in your arterial system,
you walk, supply, demand doesn't meet,
your legs start to hurt, what do you do?
You stop, it goes away, that's claudication.
And based on where the pain is,
when the person walks or exerts themselves,
you can guess where the fixed lesion is.
If they get calf symptoms, typically that's fem-pop disease.
If they get calf and thigh disease,
that's probably more common femoral.
And if they get the thigh, hip, buttock pain with impotence,
that's usually aortoiliac disease.
You can always guess where the problem is.
Now your differential diagnosis,
the most common one is spinal stenosis, pseudoclaudication.
usually Dr. Geri mentions a little bit about this
in this back pain talk,
I don't know if he did yesterday or not,
but there you have these other differentials.
The pseudoclaudication spinal stenosis classically presents
in lower extremity pain.
Classically, when a patient walks downhill,
they'll hyperextend their back,
they'll walk and then they'll get some pain in their legs.
The difference is, is the pain will last a while,
the pain will last a while before it settles down,
whereas claudication goes away
very, very quickly, within minutes of stopping.
So here we go, let's do this case.
"A 68-year-old patient presents with complaints
of aching pain in both thighs
when he or she walks about one block.
The pain subsides within one to two minutes
after he or she stops ambulating.
The best initial test in this case,"
'cause your brain is saying that sounds like iliac disease.
So am I gonna perform an ankle-brachial index?
Am I gonna perform bilateral leg ultrasounds?
Am I gonna perform a pulse volume recording
or am I gonna perform an MRA of the lower extremities?
Okay, good, ABI, that's right, that's great.
So how do you do the ABI?
It's fascinating, every time I do this lecture,
I always ask the question, raise of hands.
Everybody knows to do an ABI.
How many of you have the ability
to do an ABI in your office?
There's like a handful, there's like half dozen arms go up.
Most people can't, very easy to do,
you've probably seen it done and it goes like this,
you already have the brachial systolic pressure
when the patient walks into your office.
The nurses did that or your tech did that.
It's written in the chart before you even see the patient.
It's right there, the systolic blood pressure.
How do you go get the ankle one?
Well you just put a blood pressure cuff
around the lower extremity.
Then you take a handheld doppler,
you blow up the blood pressure cuff,
(Dr. Dachs vocalizing)
200 or whatever.
Then you put the doppler over the dorsalis pedis
or the posterior tib, you slowly let down the pressure
in the cuff and then the first,
(Dr. Dachs vocalizing)
at the ankle is a systolic blood pressure at the ankle.
So you and I hopefully have the same blood pressure
here in the arm that we have down in our ankle,
so your ratio should be one, 1.0, near 1.0.
So anything below a ratio of 0.9, below one, is a problem.
So here's how you do it again,
you can see this is how you do it with the picture.
If you do do this in office,
I love making a point on this.
This is in, "American Family Physician."
The thing that I like to point out about this
is that if you have that handheld doppler,
that's my own personal one on the right,
if you buy these for your office, they're not that crazy,
they're like $450, go get one.
They're good to have, it comes with both probes
and what I'd like to point out when they were doing this,
this one, they used the wrong probe.
The big probe is the OB probe.
You want the little vascular probe when you do this.
So you use the vascular probe, not the OB probe.
Nonetheless, that's how you do it.
And the answer for the boards is normal
is between 0.9 and 1.4, that's normal.
Below 0.9, you have potentially some disease
in your lower extremities.
People often ask me, what if it's above 1.4?
That's potentially a problem also.
What will happen is that you probably have
a very hard, thick, calcified vessel that you can't compress
and that's why you'll get an elevated number.
So the normal number is 0.9 to 1.4 for the boards.
Now let's take another question.
Let's say you are doing ABI.
Remember the American Heart Association,
American College of Cardiology,
recommends when you're obtaining your arm blood pressures,
first of all, they recommend,
I know this happens in very few offices,
I know it doesn't happen
in my primary care doctor's office when I go in,
when the patient comes in,
they should be sitting for five minutes,
both feet on the floor
before the tech comes in and takes the blood pressure.
I'm sure many of your offices don't do it,
like I say, I go and see my primary care doctor,
I come walking in and the first thing and they sit me down,
my feet are up off the thing
and they're taking my blood pressure,
that's not the way you do it.
But if you do it the right way, that's the way you do it,
you then take the higher of the two readings.
Now imagine you have a number that's 140,
let's say you have 140,
but you do it in both arms and one arm is 140
and the other arm systolic is 90.
Let's say there's greater
than 20 millimeters between the arms, huh?
If you have that, what's the most likely diagnosis,
if you have this differential between the two arms?
Is it an acute aortic dissection, chronic aortic aneurysm,
subclavian artery stenosis or a mediastinal mass or tumor?
Yeah, it's a subclavian artery stenosis.
If you get a difference between the two arms,
you think about a subclavian artery stenosis.
Now usually these are asymptomatic.
I actually only picked one up
in the ER just serendipitously.
My nurses were getting one bloods in one arm
and then we took the cuff off
and found the pressure in the other arm
was completely different.
And this patient actually was symptomatic,
she came in saying, "I'm only here
because I have some numbness or funny feeling, numbness,
in my left upper extremity."
And we had a significant difference.
So typically the patients don't know it,
until they start having some symptoms
and you don't do anything about it
until they start having symptoms,
until they start having symptoms.
Now moving downstream,
okay, let's go back to our patient with claudication.
How do you manage the patient with claudication?
On the left hand side, because this patient you now know
has some atherosclerotic disease,
you're gonna do all the stuff on the left hand side
that you normally would do anyway.
This is just risk factor modification.
This is like the no-brainer side of the slide.
You are gonna tell them to stop smoking
and you're gonna control their blood pressure and diabetes
and you're gonna need to put them on aspirin or clopidogrel,
just monotherapy, not dual antiplatelet therapy,
you're gonna put them on something.
What are the things the patient can do
to help him or her
walk longer, better, faster, without pain?
That's the right hand side.
So the answers to that is exercise, colostazol
and lipid lowering agents.
So it's been shown
that if you have supervised exercise training,
this will improve pain-free walking.
So you know this,
anytime they ask on the board if it's exercise,
you just say yes, that's a good thing, that's easy.
Lipid lowering agents have been shown
to improve pain-free walking
and drug therapy, the drug cilostazol, brand name Pletal,
people don't really know how it works,
actually we think it's a vasodilator,
but has been shown to increase pain-free walking, also.
So you have the patient who hopefully listened
to everything you told them to do,
they did exercise,
they did their drug therapy and their symptoms improve,
you do nothing.
But if your patients like my patients',
completely noncompliant, they're gonna keep smoking,
they're not gonna take their drugs
and they're not gonna exercise, what happens?
Well then their symptoms will likely worsen.
And what will happen is when their symptoms worsen,
they're gonna go from stable angina legs to...
unstable angina legs.
It's just gonna keep getting worse
and now they'll start having pain at rest.
So when they start having pain at rest, what will they do?
They'll don't like to keep their legs up now.
Now they keep putting it down,
hoping any blood will get down there.
Their legs go down, what happens?
They start getting edema of their legs,
then they start having the hair loss and the shiny legs
and the thickened nails and it'll go on and on and on
and they get cyanosis, ulceration and ultimately gangrene,
that's the the progression.
I'm gonna digress for one slide,
talk about lower extremity ulcers,
just so we we're all on the same page,
just in case you have a question on ulcers.
This is a slide actually came from, "New England Journal,"
really nice, just breaks up
the four types of lower extremity ulcers,
the venous ulcers, arterial ulcers,
neuropathic or diabetic ulcers and pressure ulcers,
the lower extremity.
You've seen all these I'm sure in your practice.
The venous ones, they're the first ones.
Those are the very superficial ones
that are often just above the medial malleolus,
they're easily fryable, you touch them, they start bleeding,
they have that brown-ey discoloration around them,
you've seen the venous.
The arterial on the other hand is when on your ankle or toe
you get this hard thickened black eschar.
You touch it, nothing bleeds 'cause it's arterial,
there's no blood getting down there.
Neuropathic is often over the bony prominences.
You can see there the typical
is the second metatarsal head.
And then the pressure ulcers
are also over those bony prominences
that are resting on the bed, typically,
on the heels and calcanei.
Alright, we come back,
back to our peripheral vascular disease.
Should you screen all patients, asymptomatic patients,
who are at risk with an ABI?
So you have a 65-year-old comes into your office,
he or she's a smoker,
yes, you're gonna order up their AAA screen,
but should you just do an ABI on them anyway?
They're at risk
and the answer to that question is we don't know.
That's it, I from the USPSTF.
Next question, let's turn the case scenario around.
"A 72-year-old patient presents to the emergency department
with sudden severe right leg pain,
sudden severe right pain,
located from the knees down to the toes.
Past history seen for hypertension, diabetes.
Vitals, the blood pressure's are good,
but the pulse is elevated and irregular.
She's afebrile, lungs are clear,
her heart's rapidly, irregular, irregular.
When you see in the boards, "Irregular, irregular,"
your brain says AFib, so AFib right leg is cool to touch,
pale and color and you can't get pulses down below.
This is a problem.
So at this point, you should, "Start heparin
and immediately consult the vascular surgeon,
B, immediately obtain an ultrasound at lower extremity,
C, immediately obtain an echocardiogram,
D, immediately obtain an abdominal aortic ultrasound."
Good, so three quarters of you got it.
Yeah, this is a thromboembolic phenomenon
that happened from the AFib.
It didn't go up to the brain and cause stroke,
it decided that clot decided to go downtown and,
(Dr. Dachs clicking)
lodge in one of the lower extremities.
So you start heparin immediately
and call your vascular surgeon.
These patients present with The 5 "P's,"
Pain, pallor, parasthesia, pulselessness, paralysis,
there's a six poichlosis, or a cold extremity.
So, we're gonna talk a bit more about this stroke
a little later, but patients with AFib,
where do these emboli that originate
typically in the atrium, where do they go?
It's interesting, about two thirds of them
go downstream into the lower extremities,
about 20% or 25% go up to the brain,
we'll talk about stroke.
Sometimes they start to go up and
(Dr. Dachs clicking) make a right or left hand turn
out to the upper extremities
or sometimes they start going downstream and
(Dr. Dachs clicking)
decide then to pop into the superior mesenteric artery
and then you get these acute SMA occlusion
and they get that and they infarct all their bowel
and they have this in incredible pain
out of proportion to physical findings.
"76-year-old patient with a history of hypertension,
hyperlipidemia and smoking."
Yeah, you know this patient.
He or she comes in with this painful toe.
"No history of trauma, no history of Afib,
the toes are dusky blue in color,
but there's pulses in your posterior tib and dorsalis pedis.
The most likely diagnosis,"
your choices are gonna be acute gout,
Raynaud's, cellulitis, blue toe.
This is blue toe syndrome.
When patients come in with painful blue toes,
that's the blue toe syndrome.
And what it is, is that those are patients at risk,
like the patient I just talked about,
what they have, their aorta, thoracic and abdominal aorta,
is all gummed up with atherosclerotic plaque,
it's this plaque all over.
And what will happen is that little bits of the plaque,
this cholesterol emboli will go,
(Dr. Dachs clicking)
shooting downstream and it'll go shooting down
into one of the digital arteries to one of your toes
and you'll end up infarcting portion or all of your toe.
There's no test for it, you can't do a blood test for it,
you can't do a CTA to figure it out or anything like that.
It's a clinical diagnosis.
What do you do about it?
You don't put them on heparin,
because it's not a blood clot,
it's a cholesterol emboli, a plaque emboli.
And so you literally treat it just like you treat frostbite,
you see what lives, what dies and you go on from there.
Last slide here, Raynaud's phenomenon.
They don't want you to call it a disease anymore,
it's a phenomenon.
And you know what it is, that recurrent vasospasm
of the fingers, toes, nose, in response to cold
and oh, it's fascinating.
3% to 5% of the population have it
and it's primary or idiopathic, we don't know what do it.
There's some people, it's due to underlying disease,
such as scleroderma.
And with that, I'm gonna say thank you very much!
(relaxing music)